good morning john so you say that i have
successfully rebranded myself away from
being a corn dog lover while you are
stuck
with being a pizza lover and i had a
little bit of a crisis about it which is
ludicrous of course but i did so we're
there the reality is like i still have a
corn dog
i'd probably prefer a corn dog to pizza
and i still eat corn dogs a lot they're
just not like part of the lore anymore
which is interesting
there's a lot of things that aren't part
of the lore anymore like a couple of
years ago
i couldn't shut up about metamucil and i
still use metamucil and i still
stand by metabolism fantastic product
that creates
good outcomes there's so much lore that
i've like forgotten about a lot of it
was i like into my little pony for a
while
like or maybe i like talked about it and
people were like actually hank back off
from that a little bit and so i just did
without really asking why why right
before i recorded this video i actually
ordered a pizza and they asked me my
name
and i said hank green and they said i
love your tick tocks and so
i asked if i could record them here it
is what do you know about me from my
tick tock
you are an intelligent well-spoken
person who brings up topics that are
very interesting
good and it's a nice educational break
in my tick tock reel so that's one
conception of who i am they didn't know
about all like the pelican stuff or the
bean
stuff or the don't eat stuff stuff and i
am on the pelican train a lot on tick
tock but like they're not the most
successful tick tocks
so that person didn't encounter them my
affinity for pelicans it's like not a
thing anywhere else i don't talk about
pelicans on twitter
that much a little bit now this raises a
question and people ask me this question
sometimes is it weird
that like you are a different person in
different places
and no it's not i don't know if this is
like because i'm
just this way or because i've been doing
it so long and i've gotten used to it or
if it's just like
people are just this way because like to
some extent we are different people to
our parents than we are to our friends
than we are to our wives than we are to
our kids and like you
not john but like you everybody else you
know that
like a facet of my job not the only
piece but a par a part of my job is that
i'm a professional performer like i
perform and i change my performance
based on
the medium and the content and the
audience any performer does that but
on the internet you're supposed to be
your authentic self and so being a
performer like that's
that's antithetical to that right except
no it's not
because you watched me become a
professional performer like if you've
seen all the vlogbrothers videos and
let's be
honest you haven't i have you know i
didn't start out a professional
performer right
like go back and watch 2007 videos not
professional caliber but also none of
these people
aren't me and the more i act
away on the internet the more i actually
am that way this isn't even a surprise
to me anymore
like you change you change your whole
life
you are different you are different one
year than you are another one but i am
in the pelicans is that something that
catherine did to me she like loved them
first and she like got me into pelicans
and i do
honestly love pizza john and i do
honestly love them ep giants and like
i there are lots of things i love do i
manufacture my quirk for the internet
i don't know that's a terrifying
question i don't think so
i have always been a goofy silly guy you
could ask my high school friend but
maybe i was manufacturing my quirks back
then
maybe we're all manufacturing our quirks
and if so it doesn't matter because
we're all manufacturing ourselves there
is no authentic self i was not born away
i have created this person that i am so
to consolidate the crisis
i am a professional internet creator
performer person
personality unless i am supposed to be
authentically myself
and i cannot be that and so here's what
i can be
authentically confused about or even
authentically disinterested in who my
authentic self
even is john i'll see you on tuesday
am i a bit much no one ever says that to
me but i think i might be a bit much
like i think if i met me i'd be like
that guy's a bit much